[Music]
thank you for the introduction yes oh
yes today I'm gonna talk to you about
our donkey cart and I call this talk
super Donkey cars because we have the
aim to improve upon the original
implementation of donkey cars but
basically it's our X excuse to play with
deep learning in the real world all
right no pictures no nothing it's it's a
car and we're gonna make it drive
automatically so what's my story so my
name is Niels I'm see how I got it the
driven I think it's a company most of
you are familiar with with you dead
science in the engineering of so Lucy so
everybody's anybody's looking for a
consultant call us I have a PhD in
parallel computing but basically I drink
coffee a lot and wise for cloud services
deploy do Dockers and iam Morris Park
it's a lot of wiping the whole day but
I'm having a lot of fun doing it so what
is the doggie car so donkey cars
actually is a it's like an open-source
self-driving platform for small scales
cars fancy sentenced basically it means
it's like an open-source community built
around one let's say platform which
allows you to very easily create your
own self-driving car and I think that's
the the the part which is most important
from this this talk is that it's it's
ridiculous how easy it is to build such
a car once you get hold of all the
components they say it's roughly two
hundred dollars to build once you import
and all the stuff here in Netherlands
it's roughly 220 euros but that's that's
the import text for you so but why are
we doing this and so it's ours that's my
excuse to play with deep learning but
it's also really nice there's
off-the-shelf components it's written in
Python so it's easily customizable and
it actually has a small community around
it so there's a select channel you can
ask questions there's quite a few
tutorials the documentation is really
well written so that's the lowest
barrier of entry of
holding your own self-driving car by a
ridiculous amount as a side note so we
do use the learning at clients an
example is this picture on the right and
dick who is from Flores gonna present
tomorrow he's over there at 10:50 I got
a sneak preview of his talk I think you
should go there so if there's a
recommendation to be made go to the top
of the neck no pressure okay so let's go
ahead and build our own donkey car so
like I said the the documentation is
really well-written so there's this read
to dogs yeah how to build your donkey to
the bagel build the first version as
well this is the improved one and
basically what they say it's easy it's
six steps you assemble a hardware
installed software you do some
calibration
start driving training and everything is
done so let's start with buying and
assembling the hardware so basically
it's built around this exceed magnet car
exceed is apparently brand of RC car you
buy it it's not really available because
since that I started building these kids
all of them are sold out to the geek
community I guess so actually we were
monitoring the slack you know one guy
posted oh there's some inventory over
there
we just bought - and imported them and
looked at the cost later but that's
that's basically the most difficult part
to get the RC car
step two is actually printing the the
frame itself so there's the orange part
and we actually use 3d hubs I know
they're yeah they're our sponsor here as
well it's like coincidence I didn't know
before it's really nice so you just
upload the making a commercial now but
anyways you upload the models to the
website and that was a guy in ISO Stan
had a 3d printer it printed these things
for me really quick and I liked it a lot
so also this 3d the nice thing of this
frame is that it's designed for the car
so it just looks built on top of it so
then the next step is you remove this
plastic shell of the car and you
disconnect the receiver it's bit small
just like the original car comes with a
with an RC receiver it just has two
jumper wires in there you just remove
the jumper wires plug off the the the
shell then you need to assemble the
frame basically so you assemble the
frame you you bolt on the by both on the
camera and use the battery to power to
PI and plug in the the motor controller
and it's those two jumper cables you
just removed from the original RC
receiver you just plug them into the
multi-core door and that's it so there's
no soldering iron involved you just pick
up the jumper cables you plug them in
the car is done it's just amazing yeah
okay so what do you didn't get like I
said so there's a there's a camera at
the front it's like this wide-angle
camera to get a nice view of the track
you have a used battery powering the
Raspberry Pi it has to be a certain
Emperor age but it's all clearly written
you have the Raspberry Pi I think most
of you are familiar with it and there's
a multi controller we bought most of the
components of Amazon if you want to go
if you order it from China and then
probably it's even cheaper than what we
get so the next step you can use any
raspbian image they have a premade image
but if you use recipe and you need to
pip install the package okay so you have
to actually use master but yeah that's
fine
and also installing the package I don't
install tensorflow chaos all of these
neural nets dependencies and it will
give you this don't we see you lie which
allows you to easily create new cars
which are there like you can have
multiple cars and that's like a
supporter that guys you have to
calibrate your car before using it and I
have this causes of tubes which are
basically datasets and you can make a
movie out of the tub I'll show all of
them in a bit so after creating a car
like I said it basically builds like
this soup folder so here I'm creating a
car called D to complete ooh it makes
supporters are from models data and logs
some models 40 models data stores your
data sets and logs is it logs some stuff
about that we're having dropping frames
and that's all stuff but I think most
important is that it creates this config
default so this line you actually need
to just does before you start and
adjusting those means that you basically
need to learn it so it's controlling
these servers for steering and also for
forward and backwards you need to
calibrate those because every car is
slightly different and after so how do
you do that basically you hold the car
in the air you start inputting different
PV pwm values you see how far to the
left and the right that the wheels turn
you get a rough estimate and then you
should do this fine tuning we skipped it
because we wanted to see if the car
worked but anyways this is from the
donut car documentation makes sense to
actually do the fine-tuning because what
you want is what I'd say in the in the
in the graph to the right you want to
have like I don't know the the good
correct that's you word for it but you
want to have an like a nice distribution
in your if you if you steer 80% you want
to also have an 80% turn let's say note
that there's a difference between
turning a fool and a bit less so this
has to be fine-tuned a bit but it's
quite easier so we skip this step
completely just looked at the wheels
turning in the air and more or less
couldn't correct
so after this collaboration you can
actually start training so you need to
build a track so first time you use some
type but it has to be clearly visible so
I think a service like this some
corporate which is really dark you need
to have a bright write something tape to
make the track visible then after you
build the track you start driving it
around and basically there you create
your data set your top
so just two ways to actually control the
car there's a web interface hosted on
the PI and you can actually use the your
built-in iPhone gyro to control the car
for me I couldn't do it but we had a
colleague who actually managed to do
this so after we actually bought this
PlayStation controller which is on the
desk here though which allows you to
control the car through bluetooth helps
a lot okay so if you actually create
this top
you basically have to drive around the
track for 10 to 20 times you have your
data set and it's basically a folder
consisting of a lot of images and this
this thing which is basically your
labels for this particular image so
these labels combined with the images
are the input of the neural net you're
going to train so I have a video
visualizing this top okay so what you
see here is the actual pictures or yeah
the video we took while training and the
steering input is at the top so you see
the left and right do you see the left
or right and the nice thing is again
this is provided to you through the
donkey car library so even this you just
get for free and you can easily debug
and remove that as the spit button so if
you went off the track you can actually
remove parts of your data set to not
train the accidentals oh yeah that's
this is a great figure sorry yeah there
is you you create multiple tops you
train your model on top of one or more
of these tubs and then you're in
business you've trained your model so
like I said also this is included
there's a simple neural net included I
think it's like a five layer I'm looking
at the like five layer neural net with
some ice it's pretty
and but default it uses like a really
low resolution images so 160 by 120
pixels I think it's mostly due to the
compute power you have on the Raspberry
Pi because yeah you have to inference
basically yeah on the on the PI training
takes a while on the PI to actually use
the AWS GPU instance but obviously that
came with a new where things are flow we
have to recompile turns the flow forearm
to get it running on the PI again and
anyways our first attempt was least
relatively successful so this is the car
now running in automated mode and the
only thing we're faking is actually the
throttle so we're doing that ourselves
which sounds like cheating but it's
actually quite a fast car and if it goes
off the track it will do something you
will not expect because it has never
seen the outside of the track so having
control of the throttle and not having a
speeding car going through the office
actually made a lot of sense yeah like I
said this this actually worked quite
well and even with the picture I I could
almost start like a self-driving company
so Diamond car company now and convinced
some investors to give me like 50
million because it's it's more or less
done but it turned out it didn't really
generalize this one model because we had
this table standing next to the track
and once we moved it we noticed that the
car wasn't turning right anymore at the
correct point in time because I didn't
really learn to turn right when the tape
went right it just learned that it had
to go right when the table was there so
we thought okay this was her first day
we had somewhat of a model and built two
cars build a model let's spend another
Friday on this and we have this concept
of god I didn't even Friday Irene we can
play around basically for a full day I
spend another Friday on this and then
we'll do the two go that is a driven
magic
we'll just make it better and
really start this new self-driving
company car company okay so next Friday
we're gonna improve it we bought the
place as you develop because training it
with with a built-in Jireh was really
difficult we fit this place and
controller increase the resolution yeah
big data more data that's what you want
and we also change the track layouts
because we needed a bigger track and
that's do this so also we did a third
attempt and we decrease the resolution
again and when I explain you why so
turned out it's maybe not the best idea
to change too many knobs at the same
time so the second attempt failed
miserably and somebody allegedly said it
was due to my driving style
I don't concur at least okay
maybe mine was true and then we had a
third attempt different driver and it
actually failed because of actual
reasons so we we started debugging it
and like I showed before this is a
snippet of the previous picture image so
you have this steering fellas right and
this joystick we bought is really nice
for driving but it's maybe not so nice
for training because the gyro we had
before it's really difficult to go from
full walk to no walk in a single go
right you you always have some
intermediate values in between but with
the joystick it's trivial right you just
push the lock you release the the the
nope and it's just zero again so this
actually causes a problem and it
actually caused our network not to
converge at all like the loss was
ridiculous so again what we learned only
change some part of the time basically
we should have only switched the
joystick and not a different track and
all these these things and also yeah we
needed to actually going to implement
some smoothly function to fix the
joystick right so if you have like a
rolling
over the joystick input maybe we will
get over this problem of these rapid
input changes so this that's the first
thing we're going to implement second I
think it's nice to have a visualizer to
see projection of neural net why I said
that we can visualize it up to be
currently there's no building function
in the donkey car library to visualize
actually the predictions of of a neural
net so I think also having depth will
allow us to debug the the donkey car
better we're gonna actually create more
deaths at some different tricks and at
the end that ever gonna beat the tesla
building first driving car based on
donkey cars because that's obviously the
correct platform to test these things
out so that's not an open question as
you see it's a it's a very much working
progress project for us we have GD
friday every four weeks if you have a
good idea you want to help you can join
maybe we'll organize a small session
around this so if you send me an email
or drop by the booth we have here we can
maybe have a fun day of hacking all
together and actually improve these
donkey cars and let everybody experience
how to how this will how nice it is to
have this this self-driving deep neural
Nets platform so that's also my
conclusion for this talk
so again highlighting I think it's it's
it's really nice access or have this
open source community around the
platform which is really plug and play
like I said just buy the components of
the internet you plug around no
soldering iron required you don't need
to mess about
yeah these PBM values seeing if your
controller will work or it just it just
works the package itself was really well
written a lot of features in there good
documentation there's a slack community
which will help you out if you run into
problems and for us it's really and for
me personally it's a really great
platform to test let's play around with
with these deep neural nets
in the world they're seeing something
move which is also a nice tangible thing
to have so with depth we're always
hiring and are there any questions and
yeah so we have one question anywhere
else in the room already two three I'm
trying to not skip people this time okay
so one two three so you mentioned that
you figured the lack of convergence of
the second attempt was due to the the
different qualitatively different inputs
yeah but you also made a much bigger
Network right so how did why do you
think it's the inputs and not the
network
okay so sure we reach as the network as
well so also this problem we had the
joystick also happened with a little
lower resolution and then sure we still
having increased the the the resolution
from this 160 to 120 to 320 and I think
okay for the maybe yeah if we go 2024
okay then you have a valid point that
probably the resolution also introduces
some problems but with this doubling
over the resolution I think it's okay
every we changed the the size of the
model accordingly and it's yeah it's
basically what we saw while training the
first echo at oh it already had like
converged which is suspicious right so
so it did convert but it didn't
generalize or yeah it converts to 2 it's
but it's still had a really high loss so
so I think yeah comparing I think the
biggest differences between the two dead
sets the first one and let's say the
third one it was the the change of the
joystick and having this really erratic
input for the first a ring all right
thank you the second one
I didn't the network of strangers to
output directly the control software
safety electronics the steering and PWM
the power or is it more sort of a high
level higher level goal that was trained
like go there or some yeah it's it's
it's it's relatively directly connected
to the PBM so while calibrating you
basically set max speed for for how fast
it goes and then that's your PV M value
and then it scales it between zero and
the max output there is no logic after
the neural net comes directly into the
yeah so it's just the steering so I have
one one further development you could do
and once we finish the self-driving part
I think it's also nice to have like a
like a car which is just following
persons might say you can do all kinds
of different neural nets all kinds of
different objectives besides just having
like a line following but yeah and I
think there's multiple neural nets
included I think by default it uses
something called a categorical and I
call it a categorical one this basically
has 15 different outputs for the the
steering and the the flow for all right
so it's not a completely linear output
okay
and question number three do you know if
it works on other RC cars as well or is
it only for the for this type I think in
general it shoot like I said I think the
nice thing is that this is completely
plug and play what I have the feeling
that most of these sensors servers they
more or less work in the same way right
they use some kind of PBM input so as
long as your servo will accept the
voltage is provided by the multi
controller and the PBM it should just
work
also while calibrating you're
calibrating basically the max speed in
the max left or right turns you would
like to see
so that should be able to adjust to any
different
RC car versus this one it's really false
when it came out of the box but for now
we kept the speed to a much lower level
because it's just too quick to XP run
around coup speed and the quick speed
would probably be used for larger tracks
but then you would have to expand and
hire a lot of people and get a really
really big office fourth question are
there any more questions for now already
by the way ok so the question is that
did you think about training and
simulated data like graphically
simulated data ok so it's funny you
should mention this so there is actually
just simulator included in the package
so you can actually use the simulator to
to generate your own their own that's
from fake images let's say then again
but you see a lot in in deep learning is
that that you modify the image is such a
bit that it's more resistant to I think
that's really tricky to do in this
setting so decide if you go simulation
yes but modifying or increasing the
amount of learning examples you have
let's say which you see a lot in
rotating images or morphing them I think
that's a bit more tricky to do in in
this guy's so because it's quite easy to
train I think just having multiple data
sets training on a lot of different
tracks should help you
sure okay so the question was with the
remark is that you can use the the
general the simulator to to initialize
your model and then more or less train
on the actual data but that's probably -
probably that's one of the reasons that
included it I've seen people on the
internet actually implementing stuff
like the ability to overtake other
donkey cars
I think that's if you won't have to
train that manually that will be really
tricky so probably they trained that in
a simulator and then just by just the
whites - to run on the particular track
okay we had a question in the back there
thank you you have any ideas on the
generalization issue to avoid it -
turning right around the table yeah
increase so basically what we did after
is we're in the track in one direction
one time and the other direction the
other time hopefully beating and this
generalization already a bit I think
just having more and more data and at
least different data if you train the
same track over and over again it will
not avoid the the table problem but if
you have more data different tracks
different settings I think that should
eventually help you overcome the trouble
but in general this is a problem of deep
learning and you know that it works you
know the input but still there's a lot
of black magic happening in between okay
thank you any further questions - Niels
Wow
okay suddenly
now I think did you repeat that sorry
okay so what you could do is you could
remove a lot of the objects let's say I
love the art of the sculpture track
let's slide establish outside of the
track so you could pre-process the
images remove all those those objects
and get a cleaner data set the final I
think yeah sure but you could also do I
think there's this coma III from geo hot
as like a self-driving thing you
building your own car I think they do
they have these line following
algorithms before the deep learning
actually runs so then you have your road
the line following algorithms actually
paints the colors and I highlight
basically the the road the yeah the
lines on the road and then it goes
through a deep Learning Network that's
also an interesting approach sure cool
and so everyone had a question please
raise your hand again and then I'm gonna
do left to right again so remember your
number one two three four okay a simple
question once you get the hang of the
track what's next okay so so okay so I
think you can get better and better at
driving a trek but what I would like is
a so this following people around
without the track I think that's a nice
feature to have and I also discovered
there's this
DJI drone this is a Python SDK so my my
ultimate play pet project would be a car
following a person and then a drone
following a car so I have like this
train around the office actually
actually the drone is interesting
because my use case would be things like
find my keys and stuff so basically this
drone it's quite interesting like a
hundred euro drone I have a Python SDK
UDP and you could just say fly four or
five four or five four and if you don't
say anything it will just hover and stop
so I think it's also a nice platform to
see if we can do something with deep
learning and the drum you figured it out
while I'm building my house and
done when I'm done are you have a nice
open space in the house it helps its in
number too so what are your thoughts
about using reinforcement learning so
you have some kind of sensor that
detects if it goes outside the track and
then in case that happens you give the
penalty and use some handcrafted funky
to move it back to the track and then
you just go away and let it learn by
itself come back next week
yeah no it's an interesting approach
every we thought about this so I think
if you were to implement that I think
you need like like a separate camera
basically absorb a observing the whole
track basically noticing that the car is
outside giving it penalty and see if you
can train a model in that way it's an
interesting approach but yeah it's an
interesting approach I don't know if if
it will work but yeah sure thanks the
next one in line is in the back would
you be able to pass this on hi you
mentioned the slack Channel right before
so how big is a self-driving RC car
community in Europe never let okay so
I'm not sure if it's that big I know one
guy who actually also built one but I
think he's doing the v1 I it's probably
bigger than just a couple guys but in
the US is definitely a lot bigger so I
think Amazon in their latest reading
event had a tutorial basically also
using donkey cars to show guys they're
using machine learning platform and also
there's some universities having these
competitions wherein you can participate
with your own donkey car like car and
see who's the quickest the wrong track
so yeah it's definitely bigger or it's a
larger community in the US but there's
bound to be a couple guys here
thank you and if we had one more
question in the back yeah maybe a little
bit related but I think it's in UK also
have the formula PI so it's actually
competition for this kind of stuff so
are you planning joining such a
competition
let's first overcome the law currently
facing but yeah it should be fun I think
I did joining such a competition or
organizing one yourself yeah why not
that's the whole point of this and this
thing it's also a reason why we bought
two so I brought one today but we have
to so it's also should be fun to have
competitions within the office already
with two of the cars cool any further
questions
so just may be more of a practical thing
so for the joystick is it that it
doesn't have intermediates or it does
have but just the user when it uses it
it completely goes crazy because this is
it what is it a practicality like you
have to put something Mac resistance in
it like play-doh in it so the rig's I
think this is almost like the second guy
alleging that is my driving which is
causing the problem that's what I'm
asking do you see intermediate values so
they implemented some features as well
for throttle that it has like a fixed
total at least because people can only
do one thing at the same time I think
once only only constraining a steering
but yeah sure if you if you're really
careful about it I think if you slowly
move the the joystick you yeah overcome
this problem so maybe with your driving
you should instead to a classifier like
fool or not okay
with this last remark on meiosis driver
skills I would like to give Niels still
a very big round of applause
[Applause]